crear es vivir dos veces dijo alvear
camino y es que para cambio la creación
es una forma de rebeldía humana contra
el absurdo quiero contarles como la
rebeldía me definió como persona y de
cómo logró generar en mí la creatividad
desde hace 30 años experimento con
sabores que excitan el paladar
la naranjilla el mortiño el tax o la
guanábana el chocolate el café
toda esta mezcla de frutas y sabores me
llevan a este increíble mundo donde las
papilas gustativas entran en un trance y
nos hacen soñar
cada bocado despierta y mi mucha
curiosidad y me lleva a otra dimensión
es abstracto y solo se siente cuando la
saliva se junta el sabor para mí
comienza el camino a la creatividad
me creía un entorno de padres
inmigrantes mi madre alemana y padre
francés llegaron después de la segunda
guerra mundial por para buscar una vida
que europa no les podía ofrecer
en mi casa se hablaban cuatro idiomas y
se servían menús de tres culturas
diferentes
esa mezcla de culturas ha hecho que yo
mire el mundo desde muchos puntos de
vista
de esa etapa de mi vida puedo decir que
fui afortunada en recibir muchos
estímulos como las artes plásticas la
música clásica el arte culinario y me
permitieron desarrollar la imaginación y
por tanto la creatividad a los 12 años
comencé a practicar el atletismo
el deporte me convirtió en una persona
disciplinada
y me enseñó la importancia de trabajar
en equipo
lo estratégico que es el deporte
competitivo la importancia de la
motivación entre compañeros y el confiar
en los demás
estudiantes visuales y comunicación en
california y seguí con mis estudios
y seguí con mi deporte tuve la suerte de
entrenar con la élite
mundial del atletismo y mi meta era
llegar a las olimpiadas
los ángeles de 1984
también jugaba fútbol en el equipo de la
universidad y desgraciadamente meses
poco pocos meses antes de las olimpiadas
me fracturé la pierna
mis sueños se vinieron abajo se terminó
mi carrera deportiva con mi tiempo
hubiera estado en la final de los 400
metros con vallas de las olimpiadas
en ese momento que pude haberme sentido
frustrada
aprendí que no hay fracasos sino
lecciones en la vida
sin embargo es un evento que marcó mucho
mi vida y me puso a prueba
y ese es un cambio muy importante
dejé la adicción a la adrenalina y me
enrumbe en el camino de la creatividad
a los 25 años
comencé a trabajar en teleamazonas como
productora del noticiero
a pesar de que era un entorno muy
interesante apasionante lleno de retos
era el trabajo era como subirse a una
montaña rusa
para mí vivir el mundo del periodismo
era vivir en un constante vértigo
sentía que necesitaba hacer algo mío
necesitaba ser mi propio jefe y sobre
todo sentía que quería ser libre
decidí hacer algo que tenga que ver con
el negocio familiar el cyrano
con mi hermano cristian
creamos con su
una heladería artesanal
un producto transparente natural
auténtico con texturas y sabores que nos
hacen acuerdo a los sabores caseros
la intención era rescatar nuestra
tradición en cuanto al helado
comenzó una nueva etapa en mi vida era
todo menos lo que había soñado
no era libre ser mi propio jefe era
durísimo
las jornadas laborales eran
interminables
la jornada
la mente no descansaba nunca siempre
estaba pensando en cómo resolver los
problemas los diez primeros años
rara vez tenía un fin de semana libre
a mis 28 años vivía mi primera
experiencia de como
de cómo ser una emprendedora un término
que hoy en día todos los milenios los
usan
si supieran lo que verdaderamente
es tratar de ser un emprendedor
logramos nuestro sueño creamos un
concepto local natural y transparente
hoy en día reciclamos del 95 por ciento
de nuestra basura
tratamos todo el agua que sale de
nuestra planta
y con eso regamos los parterres públicos
y los jardines que nos rodean
apoyamos a pequeños productores de
materias primas y creamos un espacio
donde podemos ir con nuestros amigos a
disfrutar de un helado de un café de un
desayuno conversar compartir y sentirse
parte de una comunidad
con el tiempo nos dedicamos a proyectos
agrícolas como el café y el cacao
tuvimos una plantación de café un
proyecto social que tenía como fin
mejorar las plantas de los cafetales del
ecuador
nos involucramos del proceso agrícola de
agricultura tratamos con los campesinos
entendimos sus dificultades
y hoy por hoy
tenemos una pequeña plantación de café
orgánico en galápagos y también una
plantación de cacao orgánico en las
costas de esmeraldas en que estamos
involucrados en todo el proceso desde la
siembra la cosecha la fermentación el
proceso del chocolate hasta la venta
final al cliente
el corto me dio una estabilidad
económica que me permitió incursionar en
otra dimensión creativa
en mis tiempos libres entre helados y
administración
encontré tiempo para dedicarme a las
artes plásticas
aquí comenzó este maravilloso camino que
es para mí el diseño de aplicado de
objetos utilitarios comencé a diseñar
joyas esculturas alfombras y a
experimentar con todo tipo de materiales
como la paja toquilla
el cream de caballo el bambú la cerámica
las
los textiles artesanales y los bordados
que son parte de nuestro país
es un mundo ilimitado
de infinitas combinaciones que al final
me lleva a seguir conectando ideas
existentes para encontrar nuevos caminos
en 1995 habría alquimia un espacio en
donde se juntan todas estas ideas el
concepto de la tienda es tener objetos
utilitarios diseñados por mí y por otros
diseñadores en colaboración con
artesanos
que trabajan con materiales locales y
con técnicas de nuestra cultura
el propósito es apoyar y ayudar que
mejoren sus diseños sus técnicas
enseñarles cómo valorar su trabajo sus
horas de producción y lograr que tengan
un sustento viable
en el 2002
un año muy especial para mí a los 42
años nace mi única hija momentos de
mucha alegría en la familia
pero a los pocos meses fallece mi
hermano y mi padre
compañeros de vida y de trabajo
mi vida cambia drásticamente y me pone
nuevamente a prueba
aprendí una nueva lección
aceptar
y vivir el presente
me hago cargo del negocio familiar el
cyrano
un legado familiar importantísimo
desde aproximadamente 300 años amasamos
pan en nuestra familia
para mí este entorno no era desconocido
desde muy pequeña gozaba de ir al
trabajo con mi padre me sentaba en su
mesa de trabajo y admiraba como
ensambladas sus tortas y las decorada
yo trataba de emular le hacía mis
travesuras mezclaban mis ingredientes
los sus ingredientes a mi manera y me
los comí a escondidas
desde entonces ya tenía ese bichito de
la creatividad culinaria
asumir el reto de gerenciar el cyrano
sin cuestionarme mucho tome las riendas
del negocio familiar que mi padre había
fundado en 1958
y este año estamos cumpliendo 60 años de
vida
mi día a día se desarrolla en muchos
procesos creativos desde cómo crear un
producto que puede encantar a los
paladares
pasando por las estrategias
comunicacionales y administrativas hasta
crear objetos utilitarios
la creatividad por definición no tiene
una fórmula ni una receta
las mejores ideas nacen en momentos de
atrevimiento y locura
no estudié administración de empresas y
tampoco una carrera que tenga que ver
con alimentos maneja una empresa de 400
personas creamos un promedio de 60
productos al año hacemos 800 productos
frescos todos los días logró que el día
a día mi gente sea line con la idea de
creatividad y de la innovación
ese proceso de la creatividad no se da
se da porque hay un equipo estructurado
y sólido que me acompañan aprendo con
ellos y apoyan incondicionalmente a mis
locuras
todo mi proceso desde el atletismo el
periodismo los helados artesanales la
creatividad en el mundo del arte y
finalmente tomar las riendas del negocio
familiar donde se juntan todas las fases
de mi vida ha sido un constante camino
de reinventarme tomando riesgos el abrir
el que un camino diferente al anterior
sin el afán de seguir un cliché sino de
seguir el instinto sin pensar en que
está de moda
sin pensar si va a ser importante o no
cuando uno comienza a irse por lo que
los otros están haciendo o preguntar al
consumidor qué es lo que quiere y seguir
las las tendencias de las redes sociales
es demasiado tarde
para ser innovadores hay que aprender a
buscar caminos diferentes e inusuales
sean creativos
miren dentro de ustedes observen el
comportamiento de la sociedad que les
rodea
juntos en con seres creativos
compartan sus ideas con otros es así que
se logra la innovación
busquen muchas opciones para el mismo
concepto
un concepto nuevo es la combinación de
ideas existentes que luego evolucionan
sueñen mucho
y sobre todo desacelera en sus mentes
desconecte zinc
tengan momentos de aburrimiento
mediten
porque es en ese momento que la mente
comienza a pensar diferente
y es creativa
tengan la valentía de seguir su pasión
de equivocarse
y de seguir su intuición confíen en sus
ideas y trabajen mucho en ellas
viva en el presente intensamente como
predican los budistas
hay que disfrutar el camino más que
llegar a la meta
esta es mi historia
de cómo ser deportista artista creativa
y desestructurada
tube ideas para crear emprendimientos
que de alguna manera
mejora la vida de las personas que están
involucrados en estos proyectos
y reinventarse continuamente es un
camino intenso
lleno de pasión
retador y extremadamente gratificante
y como dijo el vez que a mí
crear
es vivir dos veces muchas gracias
[Aplausos]